يعني ساعات كانت داميه سواء على مخيم
النصيرات على منطقه الزوايده حتى على دير
البلح والمغازي والبريج وحتى رفح وخان
يونس وجميع محافظات قطاع غزه طالها القصف
الاسرائيلي العنيف ربما هذه الليله واحده
من الليالي الاعنف في وسط قطاع غزه على
الاقل في ظل استهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي
لمنازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وبالتالي الناس
تكون نائمه في هذا الوقت من الليل او حتى
من ساعات الصباح الاولى وبالتالي يدمر هذه
المنازل على رؤوس السكان وعشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى في كل مره من في ظل
استمرار الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه السياسه
باستهداف المنازل الفلسطينيه وتدميرها على
رؤوس السكان في مخيم النصيرات هناك منزلين
المنزل الاول لعائله جبر في مخيم واحد في
مخيم الصيرات وسط قطاع غزه وعشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى في بلوك سي في عائله منزل
عائله صيدم وايضا دمر وسوي بالارض على
رؤوس السكان وهناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
بالتالي كان حصيله هذين المنزلين فقط 20
شهيدا وعشرات الاصابات من جراء هذا
الاستهداف وتدمير هذه المنازل وما نقل حتى
الان هم من المنازل المحيطه فنحن نعرف ان
مخيم النصيرات هو مخيم مكتظ مخيم النصيرات
هو المنازل فيه متلاصقه وبالتالي عشرات من
المنازل اصلا في بلوك سي هي منازل من
الصفيح ومنازل بدائيه وبالتالي اي قصف
اسرائيلي يحدث اضرار جسيمه ودمار هائل في
المنزل المستهدف وفي المنازل المحيطه وما
ينقل في الساعات الاولى على الاقل هم من
المنازل المحيطه لا سما ان المنزل
المستهدف يكون دمر سويا بالارض ولا تستطيع
طواقم الدفاع المدني انتشال الجثامين من
تحته وبالتالي ما تم نقله حتى الان هم 20
شهيدا وما زال البحث جاري كما في كل صباح
تقوم طواقم الدفاع المدني بعمليات تمشيط
اسفل تلك المنازل المستهدفه وتعمل على
البحث عن مزيد من من هؤلاء الج من هذه
الجثامين التي ما تزال تحت الانقاض في
مخيم المغازي ايضا استهدف الطائ استهدفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه منزلا كذلك
ودمرته وسوته بالارض ونقل الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى ثماني شهداء وعدد من الجرحى
والمصابين وفي كل هذه المنازل على الاقل
في وسط قطاع غزه كل ما نقل الى هذه
المستشفى هم اطفال ونساء وعدد قليل من
الرجال وبالتالي لان هذه المنازل تكون
مكتظه والرجال يتركون المنازل اصلا للنساء
ويبقون في الخارج يعني كما هي العاده وكما
جرت العاده عند هؤلاء بالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي مازال حتى هذه اللحظه مستمر
لكنه ربما الاكثر والاكثر كثافه من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تواصل قصفها
لجميع المناطق لا سما شرق مخيم المغازي
شرق مخيم البريج وشرق مخيم النصيرات ولعل
القصف الاكثر كثافه هو على مخيم البريج
ولكن نحن لم نتحدث عن مخيم البريج لاننا
لا نستطيع الوصول لا نحن ولا سيارات
الاسعاف ولا سيارات الدفاع المدني مخيم
البريج لا يبعد سوى اقل من كيلومتر واحد
عن هنا عن مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ولكن رغم
كل ذلك نحن لا نستطيع الوصول الى هذا
المخيم الجيش الاسرائيلي والطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه دمرت مداخل المخيم
وتقصد بعنف كل ما يتحرك في هذا المخيم
والدبابات الاسرائيليه التي تقدمت في
المناطق المفتوحه تقصد بالقذائف بعشرات
القذائف في كل لحظه وفي كل حين هذه
المناطق وبالتالي كل مناطق المنطقه الوسطى
بعدما تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي انه بدا
عمليه عسكريه في هذه المنطقه باتت تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه ومن الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه كذلك ش شمال مخيم
النصيرات منطقه ارض المفتي المغرا ومدينه
الزهراء يتعرضون لقصف مكثف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وبالتاكيد هذا ليس
القصف الوحيد وربما التركيز على المنطقه
الوسطى لان العمليه العسكريه الجديده التي
بدات هي بدات في المنطقه الوسطى لكن القصف
المكثف مستمر في المناطق الشرقيه لخان
يونس في منطقه بن سيلا وخزاعه والقرار
وعبس وهي ما زالت محاصره وتمنع وتمنع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الدخول لطواقم
الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني الى هذه
المناطق وبالتالي من يصاب في تلك المناطق
يبقى على الارض او يستشهد وهو ينزف على
الارض ويبقى ويبقى ملقى على الارض ولا
تستطيع الطواقم الوصول اليه ايضا في
المناطق الشرقيه ل تعرضت الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وايضا شنت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه غارات على مدينه رفح
ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى مجزره كبيره
بالقرب من المستشفى الكويتي كانت عندما
نفذت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه غاره
على منزل وعندما نتحدث عن رفح فلح خصوصيه
لان الجيش الاسرائيلي بات يطلب من السكان
كل قطاع غزه بات يتركز في منطقتين
اساسيتين هما مدينه رفح في جنوب قطاع غزه
ودير البلح في وسط القطاع واي غاره على
هذه المناطق معناه ان هناك عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى لان المنازل مكتظه عن
بكره ابيها الشوارع نفسها مكتظه بالخيام
مكتظه بالنازحين مكتظه بكل من حاول اللجوء
الى تلك المناطق الامنه بعدما بات القصف
يقترب اكثر فاكثر من المنازل التي كانوا
يتواجدون فيها في خان يونس وفي المخيمات
الوسطى وفي مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع
وبالتالي القصف على رفح كان مكثفا
وبالتالي كان هناك عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى لا سياما وان كما تحدثنا هناك
عشرات بل الاف النازحين باتوا يتواجدون في
مدينه رفح في الشوارع في منازل الاقارب في
مراكز الاواء لا يوجد متسع ولا لقدم واحده
في مدينه رفح وبالتالي كل الاماكن باتت
مكتظه اي قصف اسرائيلي على مدينه رفح التي
تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي للسكان وقال لهم
توجهوا الى مدينه رفح معناه ان هناك عشرات
من الشهداء والجارى وعشرات من المفقودين
الذين سيبقون تحت الانقاض لانه لا يوجد
اليات ولا معدات ثقيله تستطيع من خلالها
طواقم الدفاع المدني انتشال هذه الجثامين
وهؤلاء الجرحى ونقل عدد من الشهداء الى
مستشفى الكويتي من جراء هذه الغاره وهناك
داد من الاصابات وكما هنا في المنطقه
الوسطى تعمل طواقم الدفاع المدني في رفح
على انتشال مزيد من الجثامين والشهداء في
ساعات الصباح الاولى كما تعمل على تمشيط
كل المناطق التي قصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
للبحث عن ان كان هناك جرحى ان كان هناك
شهداء ايضا في مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع
القصف ما زال مستمرا ومركزا على حي الدرج
في مدينه غزه القصف ايضا يستهدف حي الشيخ
رضوان ويستهدف حي الشجاعيه الذي ما زال
ايضا هو الحي المحاصر وكما تسمع القصف
المدفعي لم يتوقف في كل لحظه وفي كل حين
هناك مزيد من القصف المدفعي على المناطق
الشرقيه لا سما البريج وايضا المغازي
وكذلك حي الشجاعيه الذي هو ما زال محاصرا
القصف مركز في حي الشجاعيه وايضا في حي
الدرج الذي الذي بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي على
ما يبدو عمليه بريه باتجاه هذا الحي
الواقع في منطقه مدينه غزه في المناطق
الشرقيه الشماليه لمدينه غزه ايضا القصف
مستمر في منطقه جباليا منطقه بيت لاهيا
وان كانت القوات الاسرائيليه اعادت
التموضع التمركز في كثير من هذه المناطق
تراجعت الدبابات الاسرائيليه عن بعض
المناطق وعادت لتتمركز في مناطق مختلفه
وبالتالي الناس الذين يتوجهون الى المناطق
التي التي انسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولوج جزئيا يكتشفون حجم الجرائم
الاسرائيليه من تدمير كبير في تلك المناطق
لا سما بيت حنون التي شاهدنا صورا مرعبه
من تلك المنطقه دمار هائل ربما لا يوجد
منزل ما زال قائما على قائما على الارض
وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي هو مركز في كل
مناطق قطاع غزه ويستهدف في جله منازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه هشام زقوت من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى بدير البلح شكرا
جزيلا